it's so shameless isn't it I keep saying
that's terrible really
no I'm not really remotely positive no
no no I dunno it's been such an amazing
year for women yeah no but I have to say
it really hasn't actually the Supporting
Actress category I think is the one
custards been really talked about people
have been floating in and out of the
category our award season so to to just
be here
it's just feels really good needs to do
more yes absolutely I think it's
something that needs to happen at the
grassroots you know I know personally
when I get a script and the lead
characters will always be presumed to be
white unless it specifies otherwise and
I think you know change needs to happen
at the grassroots so it's good that it's
coming to the front now and people are
discussing it and hopefully we'll start
seeing some change you know what it
feels amazing to be invited back frankly
we had an amazing time making the Danish
girl and it was an intense film to make
what a wonderful one and and you
you hope the story resonates and being
here you hope that that validates that
in some way
there's about transgender an issue which
is getting more and more attention in
the time absolutely I mean I suppose one
of the things that sort of astounded me
is certainly in the past two years trans
issues have come to the forefront of
media attention but it's almost a
hundred years since skirt or and Lily's
story it's kind of shocking that it's
taken quite so long and and I hope I
just took a film in some way continues
the discussion my favorite of the year I
mean it's such a gorgeous gorgeous
portrayal of homesickness it was very
personal to you wasn't it this day it
was yeah I mean it was very very
important for me can you as soon as
possible to be involved in an Irish
phone and to be involved in an Irish
film I felt was really kind of gonna
represent us and it could be something
that we were we were proud of and um and
so I think with that came an awful lot
of responsibility but this felt like the
right first Irish project to take on and
the fact that it was about leaving home
and I had just left home with those it
made it even more emotional who goes
over to New York in the 50s from Ireland
isn't it so nice it's very touching you
know you can sort of specifically say
okay after there Ireland enough about
America and that sort of a lie
it's really just about anyone who's ever
left home I'm sure you felt that way
when you left home at first and I know
what you did and everyone goes through
that stage where they don't quite know
where they belong anymore and that's
what the film is between a focused on is
her coming to terms with that and
accepting it and OH
honestly I just I felt like I was
pregnant he is with a baby could Star
Wars and when Star Wars came out it
didn't belong to us the way it used to
so it's good to share the excitement
with everybody now you think is an issue
that something more needs to be done
about yeah I think the conversation is
great but I think I'm an individual
person I want to be the change I want to
see so I'm out here working and making
sure that that gets done but the
conversation is definitely positive and
continue that I think it was more for me
when I read the script I was kind of I
couldn't believe that I didn't know more
about this couple even a line it was
hard for me to find any information and
that they're you know that the first
gender confirmation surgery happened so
early on so for me I just felt more you
know most of all just excited to be part
of telling a story that I was happy that
I got introduced to myself through the
script